ich habe im letzten Jahr
850 000 € für Videos ausgegeben wie sich
diese Zahl zusammensetzt welche Videos
wir gedreht haben welche Videos wir
gedreht haben die aber nie online
gekommen sind und warum das Jahr 2024
für euch als Zuschauer noch mal viel
krasser wird erfahrt ihr in diesem Video
all das in fünf steps ein Rückblick auf
die Videos in 2023 die Kosten aus 2023
Videos die nie gekommen sind obwohl wir
sie gedreht haben das Jahr in Zahlen und
ein Vorblick auf
2024 2023 war auf meinem Kanal geprägt
von Serien und wie sollte es anders sein
wir starten mit der Banger Serie die
meinen Kanal auf neue Höhen geschossen
hat Porsche tradeup Porsche Modelle
verkauft ai Fotos automatisiert
verkaufen und natürlich nach golfbäen
tauchen was vielen von euch im
Gedächtnis geblieben ist all das um in
die zweite Serie zu rutschen den 944
umzubauen nach meinen Träumen nach Euren
Träumen zu dem absoluten Offroad Monster
das es am Ende geworden ist um damit
eine Rally zu fahren das Auto dann an
jemanden von euch zu verschenken
zwischendurch natürlich immer wieder
dhdl Produkte testen eine Serie die sich
sehr großer Beliebtheit erfreut hat von
der wir uns aber in 2023 mit der letzten
Folge für immer verabschiedet haben dann
natürlich alle 100 € in und so lebt man
in aus Japan Vietnam Kuba und unzähligen
anderen Ländern Serien indem wir uns
anschauen wie weit wir mit einem
bestimmten Betrag in einem Land kommen
oder wie Menschen in anderen Ländern
leben natürlich nicht zu vergessen die
Serie mit der ich meine Ehre
wiederherstellen konnte 7 Tage in
Schweden mein sevenb wi zweitversuch ich
raste aus Mann aus dieser Serie ging es
zurück wieder ins Business Leben ich
habe ein Startup gegründet und das in
einer fünfteiligen Serie begleitet save
it die App mit der ihr alle beim online
shopenbes Geld sparen könnt den gesamten
Prozess begleitet und das auch als Serie
bei mir auf dem Kanal gebracht und nicht
zu vergessen die ganzen einzelnen
bangerv Videos die keiner Serie so
wirklich zuzuordnen sind wie das
teuerste Zugticket der Welt Orient
Express inem wir von Venedig bis nach
Paris gefahren sind oder natürlich auch
die Geisterstadt in Malaysia außerdem
habe ich natürlich den günstigsten 992
GT3 Deutschlands gekauft meinen
absoluten Traumwagen als Unfallwagen die
Serie die immer noch läuft und die uns
auch in 2024 noch begleiten wird
unglaublich wie viel unterschiedlichen
Kram wir als Content für euch auf meinem
Kanal bringen konnten was das in Zahlen
bedeutet wie viel Zeit wir investiert
haben in wie vielen Ländern wir waren
wie weit wir fahren mussten was am Ende
an Views und so weiter dabei
rausgekommen ist erfahrt ihr später als
erstes schauen wir uns aber an wie viel
Kohle ich dafür investieren musste aua
aua aua an fix also laufenden Kosten im
Monat wie Büro Software Strom und so
weiter noch bevor wir irgendwas
gearbeitet haben hatten wir Kosten von
80.000 € im Jahr 2023 und ich nenne das
als erstes denn es ist der kleinste
kostenpunkt weiter geht's mit kosten die
einfach für die Produktion anfallen also
reisen irgendwohin Hotels vor Ort Dinge
die wir für Videos kaufen mussten die
mit 150 000 € also etwas über 3000 € pro
Video zu Buche schlagen denn wir haben
47 Videos im Jahr 2023 veröffentlicht
und hier gilt natür natürlich zu
verstehen manche Videos wie Höhle der
Löwen Produkte Test kostet uns 300 €
weil wir die einzelnen Produkte kaufen
andere Videos wie Orient Express kosten
uns 19 000 € fürs Zugticket ein paar
1000 € für Hinreise Abreise und so
weiter kostet dann am Ende irgendwie
sowas wie 23 oder 24 000 € pro Video das
ist also extrem unterschiedlich und
jetzt kommen wir zum größten kostenpunkt
zum verdien größten kostenpunkt nämlich
dem Gehalt insgesamt habe ich
266 000 € für Gehälter ausgegeben
inklusive meines Gehaltes von 3000 €
netto im Monat was richtig ordentlich
ist aber eben auch wichtig damit die
Leute die für mich und an den Videos
Arbeiten vernünftig entlohnt werden
weitere 200.000 € die ich jetzt einfach
mal mit eingerechnet habe weil sie
essentiell für diese Serie waren sind
das 200.000 € saved Investment dieses
Geld ist natürlich nicht weg und ist
nicht grundsätzlich als Kosten für die
Produktion zu verstehen aber es ist
essentiell damit die Serie funktioniert
genauso wie der Porsche den ich jetzt
einfach mal grob weil ich noch nicht zu
viel verraten will mit 150 000 €
berechnet hab insgesamt sind es also
Kosten von ca 850 000 € mit SAV IT und
Porsche auf der anderen Seite 496 000 €
an Kosten im Jahr 2023 ohne irgendwelche
Investments oder Anlage wie man unschwer
erkennen kann ist aus dem einfach mal
ein paar Youtube Videos drehen echt ein
großes Ding geworden um ehrlich zu sein
ein zu großes Ding kleiner Vergleich wir
hatten in 2023 deutlich mehr kosten als
wir in 2021 überhaupt ins gesamt an
Umsatz gemacht haben also es geht
relativ schnell und um ehrlich zu sein
sind es zu viele kosten ja viele der
Ausgaben sind wichtig andere sind aber
wirklich komplett unnötig und mein
großes Ziel für 2024 ist es das besser
in den Griff zu bekommen damit euch das
auch besser gelingt gibt es finanzguru
den Partner des heutigen Videos mit
finanzguru seht ihr nämlich auf einen
Schlag gebündelt alles was reinkommt und
viel wichtiger eben alles was rausgeht
zu oft verliert man den Überblick
vergisst irgendwelche Abos zu kündigen
und schleppt unnötige Kosten von Monat
zu Monat mit sich die Reg istriert durch
künstliche Intelligenz regelmäßige
Kontobewegung hilft euch also dabei
besser zu verstehen wo was reinkommt wo
was rausgeht und sogar Verträge direkt
in der App rechtss sicher zu kündigen
dabei könnt ihr super einfach euer
Girokonto Sparkonto Aktiendepot und
sogar PayPal direkt mit der App
verbinden und sofort losstarten das
Beste das ganze ist komplett kostenlos
zusammengefasst ist es die perfekte
Möglichkeit um im neuen Jahr einmal
komplett mit seinen Finanzen aufzuräumen
und alles perfekt im Blick zu haben und
mehr Geld für die schönen Dinge zu haben
wie immer erhaltet ihr mit meinem Code
in diesem Fall Dave 204 20 3 Monate
finanzgo plus komplett kostenlos zum
Testen damit seht ihr heute schon was
ihr morgen auf dem Konto habt und
intelligente Budgets helfen euch beim
Sparen aber euch erwartet noch ein
kleines nachträgliches
Weihnachtsgeschäft denn unter all den
Leuten die sich mit dem Code Dave 2024
bis Ende Januar bei finanzburro
registrieren verlost finanzguru dreimal
ein Jahr finanzguru plus komplett
kostenlos also ersten Link in der
Videobeschreibung abchecken registrieren
Code Dave 2024 eingeben und eure
Finanzen in den Griff bekommen Vielen
Dank finanzgu für die Unterstützung und
euch viel Spaß weiter mit dem Video aber
wie auch bei den Finanzen läuft nicht
immer alles nach Plan wir haben eine
Menge Videos gehabt die am Ende nie das
Licht der Welt erblickt haben ich
erzähle euch aber nur von den Videos die
wir gedreht haben die NIE online
gekommen sind alle Ideen die am Ende
irgendwie nicht funktioniert haben lasse
ich hier raus die würden den Rahmen
komplett sprengen beispielhaft habe ich
jetzt einfach mal sechs Videos genommen
die nie rausgekommen sind es gab aber
noch ein paar mehr starten wir beim
Sunrise zo einem unheimlich legendären
schlafzug der einmal quer durch Japan
führt den wir gefahren sind indem wir
geschlafen haben bei dem das Video am
Ende aber nicht groß genug nicht toll
genug nicht vernünftig genug von uns
ausgearbeitet war als dass wir bereit
gewesen wären es auf dem Hauptkanal zu
bringen ziemlich schade wir haben eine
komplette Nacht gedreht und es war auch
wirklich eine geile experience aber es
hat einfach nicht gereicht wenn ihr
diese Videos trotzdem mal sehen wollt
lasst es mich in den Kommentaren wissen
vielleicht bringe ich sie einfach auf
dem zweitkanal oder irgendwann für
kanalmitglieder hier auf dem Kanal
ähnlich legendär geht's weiter Singapur
Marina Bay Hotel Test eins der
legendärsten Hotels überhaupt auf dieser
Welt haben wir getest testet haben
richtig Kohle investiert und am Ende war
es einfach nicht spektakulär genug als
dass es für ein Video gereicht hätte
dieses legendengefühl mit dem wir die
ersten Schritte im Hotel gemacht haben
wurde einfach überhaupt nicht bestätigt
es war teuer es hat uns überhaupt nicht
aus den Socken gehauen und am Ende waren
wir sogar ziemlich enttäuscht und haben
deswegen gedacht der Weib vom Video
passt nicht wir lassen es sein genau aus
demselben Grund haben wir ein Video über
eins der wenigen sieben Sterne Hotels
dieser Welt in Venedig was uns auch
richtig Kohle gekostet hat nie gebracht
damit sie Vorspeise ich schwöre ich
kenne die Tomaten von
Gorillas die Kosten 19,9 ich schwöre das
kostet 38 € jetzt
hier ja sind lecker wie E und je als
nächstes eine komplette Videoreihe
nämlich alle Videos die wir in Dubai
gedreht haben sind niemals online
gekommen und das aus verschiedenen
Gründen wir wollten schauen wie lebt man
günstig Vers teuer in Dubai haben uns
ein 150 Millionen Euro Apartment
angeschaut was wirklich beeindruckend
war ein Apartment das im Besitz von
einer Person aus der Königsfamilie ist
wunderbar mega gutes Material gesammelt
aber uns wurde das günstige Apartment
abgesagt das bedeutet wir hatten nichts
zum Vergleichen und einfach nur ein
teures Apartment wollten wir nicht
zeigen was sehr sehr schade ist genauso
sah es mit dem 100 € in bzw 1000 € in
Dubai Video aus am Ende wurden uns
Termine abgesagt wir hatten einen halben
super coolen Tag und am Ende die zweite
Hälfte des Tages ist komplett ins Wasser
gefallen und wir hatten zu wenig
Material zumindest bin ich das erste Mal
in meinem Leben Lamborghini
gefahren das war sehr cool genauso
sieht's mit der fitnessransformation aus
die ich mittlerweile schon zwei oder
dreimal angefangen habe bei der aber nie
ein wirklich gutes Ergebnis rumkam weil
ich immer schnell genug Ausreden
gefunden habe um mit dem Sport
aufzuhören Fitness Trafo steht aber
immer noch sehr weit oben auf der Liste
für die kommenden Jahre und kommenden
Projekte und noch viele weitere Sachen
hoteltest in Japan Onsen hotspring fünf
Sterne Hotel dies das und jenes also wir
haben wirklich wahrscheinlich noch 10
oder 15 fertig gedrehte Videos die
vermutlich auch niemals kommen werden
schade aber so ist es viel wichtiger als
die Videos die nicht gekommen sind sind
aber natürlich die Videos die gekommen
sind was das in Zahlen bedeutet in
Aufwand und so weiter schauen wir uns
jetzt an insgesamt bin ich im letzten
Jahr über 50.000 km geschäftlich
gefahren also um Interviews einzusammeln
oder irgendwo zu drehen hab 15 Länder
bereist darunter Kanada Thailand Vietnam
und viele viele weitere hatte 324
Arbeitstage und habe 114 Nächte nicht im
eigenen Bett verbracht war also quasi
ein Drittel des Jahres auf Montage
rausgekommen dabei sind 47 Videos ca
7000 Stunden Rohmaterial was völlig
verrückt ist 34 TB Daten vier kaputte
SD-Karten was problematisch ist weil es
bedeutet dass wir viermal Daten verloren
haben und über 2000 Stunden im
Videoschnitt Ergebnis davon und dafür
schaue ich kurz in die Liste 48,3
Millionen Views Longform 3,5 Millionen
Likes auf Videos über 50.000 Kommentare
335 000 neue Abos aber auch 115 000 Abos
verloren und 7,3 Millionen Stunden
Wiedergabezeit was
304000 Tage oder 833 Jahre sind die
Leute meine Videos angeschaut haben
bedeutet umgerechnet müsste eine Person
all die Zeit vor meinen Videos
verbringen die ihr vor meinen Videos
verbracht habt müsste sie 833 Jahre
nonstop meine Videos
schauen am Ende sind wir alle darauf
mächtig stolz und möchten danke sagen
2024 wird von uns komplett neu
durchorganisiert wir wollen alles besser
machen alles toller machen größere
Projekte und vor allem einfach weiterhin
unheimlich guten Content vielen Dank für
eure Unterstützung im Jahr 2023 ich bin
unglaublich happy dass alles hier so
machen zu können und freue mich riesig
aufs Neue Jahr jetzt erstmal vier
weitere Folgen 992 GT3 wieder inst
bringen dann geht's weiter mit Dokus
großen Projekten und vielen tollen Ideen
macht's gut bis dahin ciao
[Musik]